foreign
[Music]
it's a problem that we have in this
country there needs to be a culture of
accountability that's what needs to come
back is a culture of accountability
you have his text and you have
confirmation photographic confirmation
that he was at a place where he would
have been with his dad that in and of
itself does open you up to a national
security issue so this is the problem is
the law enforced equally
are there children in there I haven't
been in there I do not think so find me
one single member of the DNC
International level who condemns a man
shaking his penis in front of a child
riding a tricycle one this is about
saving American Ingenuity from the Hawks
who very often come in to destroy a body
and pick up the carcass for a select few
while the rest of you are left to pick
at the scraps and they must be exposed
at every opportunity because they
operate at the expense of someone you
know and it could just as easily and
very likely is you
I'm not trying to like be a provocateur
I'm just trying to get a real answer
because I never give a real answer
have you thread that needle of
inclusivity being welcoming while also
stopping some Fentanyl
coming back to take over to make sure
that they know that you are out there
they have eyes on them and that life
just isn't going to be that easy